is the 14-inch macbook pro really worth  a thousand dollars more than the m1  macbook air the pro looks bigger bulkier  a bit meaner where the air is thinner  and sleeker in my opinion and if you  type a lot you'll probably prefer the  air that 14-inch pro has the best  speakers in any laptop of this size  [Music]  i would kind of just track how often you  use those ports you just have to ask  yourself is it really worth spending  twice as much money to have them built  in instead of buying a cheap  multi-adapter  in the real world the air has more than  enough performance for almost everybody  because it smoked even the expensive  high-end 16-inch macbooks in the past  there are only a few people who i would  say that actually need the extra oomph  of the 14-inch and for a lot of those  people i would say you need even more  power you should spend even more money  than this base two thousand dollar model  that we're comparing to the air